[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for watching this was a big
endeavor for all of us here and I think
this side-by-side really kind of shows
how much effort goes into something like
this I mean we've spent two months
working on that video and this side by
side was actually brought to you by
motton Bao and who are they good
question
they make jeans Mun Bao has mastered the
art of making the perfect pair of jeans
they use high-quality Dems with really
high-class manufacturing processes and
they are half the price of other premium
brands and you can actually buy like a
couple different sizes of jeans and
whichever one fits you the best is the
one you can keep and you can return the
other one damata now if you like now
today I've actually gotten two pairs of
jeans so I'm gonna be testing if they
are as high quality as they're
advertised to be I've yet to see him at
all these are genuine finite homegrown
gmo-free reactions a black pair of shoes
that actually does have a decent amount
of stretch to it these are gonna be so
comfy I have these crappy little pants
look at this they ripped from my phone
in my pocket alright I'm gonna try these
on now I think these are gonna fit
really well these are pants have got a
good knot right look at that
doot-doot
what is this stretchy if I was that
stretchy as my pants I'd do the splits
I'm not that stretchy
click the link below or go to motton
baucom slash corridor group to get 20%
off your first purchase just get in
there okay yeah yeah good look I promise
wait the plane smash bros